[Applaudissements]
ça fait un carton à angoulême lundi
nerveux je m'en fous moi aussi j'ai des
dîners moi aussi j'ai ma vie c'est parti
alors attention oui on mélange est allé
aux mains attention vous mettez la main
mettez votre main de ses chais la neige
et les médecins de regard vous avez vu
tout entendu
non attention à 2 2 3 radars
[Applaudissements]
l'affiché non
si vous avez choisi la même camille
malheureusement monsieur l'excusé que je
t'aime beaucoup tu vas faire donc le
masque de 15 minutes plus tôt merci le
masque de carnaval pour camille combal
alors qu'ici il ya maintenant des vidéos
sur alors oui attention
camille camille la mijaurée de le faire
mon bébé tackels si la wii mais je suis
toi mon chéri doug et bien c'est pas les
jours pas les yeux jamais les yeux je
sais mon le fond à la à la série là dans
ton manteau bleu menthe ou du champion
n'en tombe champions la barre à la rue
et le nez tu senti si on regarde et le
nez le nez le nez de dorothée qu'on se
le dise tenir à cette année dans sa
valise toi tu fais comme ça attention
j'avais enfin vers le bol
montella
je dors
m
ça va dans le cas du sahara les vieux
temps chaud comme ça les yeux ça va les
yeux attention les séries attendez
attendez attendez je vais vous dire ce
qui va se passer maintenant
donnez moi ça merci mes chéris on va
jouer au corcovado dans un instant